.
Now I want to solve the variants containing
Absolute values
If there is a subject in algebra it confuses
People are very much a subject
But if we keep directly what
It means absolute value, I think you will find it
Not so bad
Let's start with a simple warm-up issue
Let's start with | x | <12
Remember what I told you about
The meaning of absolute value
It means distance from zero
If the first method is to say: What are all x values ​​that are
Is less than 0 by less than 12?
Let me draw a line of numbers
If it 's zero here, we turned to all setups
From zero to less than 12, well, you can turn
To positive 12, you can turn to -12
Anything between these two numbers will be
Absolute value less than 12
Its distance from zero will be less than 12
If you can say, these can be all setup
So that x is -12
No doubt those numbers will be worth less absolute
Of 12, as long as it is also - and x must
Be less than 12
If X touches any of these restrictions, it will be
Its absolute value is less than 12 without a doubt
As you know, when you take the absolute value of -6
It is less than zero
| -11 Is less than zero by 11
If anything achieves both of these limitations conditions
Will achieve this equation
In fact, we have solved it, because this is about
Equation of one step
But I think it's a good foundation for the following examples
I can write it like this
In this space everything will be between
12 - and does not include those numbers
Or we can write it like this, x <12
> -12
This is the solution set
Now let's solve more complex examples
Let us think a little harder
So let's assume that we have | 7x |
> = 21
So let's not think about what is inside
Now the absolute value code
So that the absolute value is anything
Greater than or equal to 21, what does this mean?
It means that whatever exists within the absolute value code
Whatever exists within our absolute value code
It must be less than zero by 21 or more
Let me draw a line of numbers
In fact, you should imagine a line when setting up
Do this, so you will never get upset
You should not save any rule
So let's put a zero here
Let us appoint Mojib 21, and appoint 21 here
We want all the numbers, whatever that is
Values ​​will be greater than or equal to 21
It is far from zero by more than 21
Their absolute values ​​are greater than 21
Well, all these negative numbers are less than
-21, when we take absolute values, when
We get rid of negative sign, or when we find
After zero, they will be greater than 21
If you take an absolute value of -30, they will
Will be greater than 21
Here too, anything larger than positive 21
Its absolute value will be greater than 21 as well
If we can say that 7x must equal one of the
These numbers, or that 7x should equal one of these
The numbers are here
If we can write that 7X must be one of these numbers
Well, what are these numbers?
These are all numbers that are less than or equal to
21, or 7x - let me use a different color here - or that's 7x
It must be one of these numbers
This means that 7x must be greater than or equal to
Positive 21
I really want you to understand
What's happening here
If the absolute value is greater than or equal to 21
This means that what is inside the absolute value code must be
Either greater than positive 21
Or less than -21
Because if it is less than -21, when you take
Its absolute value, beyond zero, will be more than 21
I hope this makes sense
We will solve more exercise issues, because it is
Stabilize in your brain
But once you master them, these become
Differentiated vehicle, we divide the two ends of this equation on
7, and we get x <= -3
Or divide the two sides on 7, we get x
> = 3
I want to be very clear
This, whatever I drew here, was not the solution
It even has to be equal to 7x
I wanted you to imagine what it meant to be
The absolute value is greater than 21, ie
Is far from zero by more than 21
This is a set solution, x must be larger than or
Equal to 3, or less than or equal to -3
If you set the solution to this equation - let me draw
Line numbers - let's assume that zero, and those 3, these are
-3, the x must either be greater than or equal to 3
Greater than or equal to 3
That is the sign of equality
Or less than or equal to -3
We're done
Let us solve more of these examples
It's annoying to think, but if
Began to realize the core of absolute value, they
Will become intuitive
So let's assume that we have absolute value - let me
I put a good example -
Let's say <5x + 3 <7
If this tells us that whatever it is inside
The absolute value code, after which the zero must be less than 7
If the roads have a distance of less than 7, then call me
Draw a line setting - if the methods can be zero from zero in
7, can be less than 7, bigger than
is not it?
We must be in these limits
And even achieve what exists in the absolute value code
It must be - the thing inside the absolute value symbol
It is 5x + 3 - it must be bigger than
7. It must be less than 7, in order
The absolute value shall be less than 7
If 5x + 3 resides somewhere here
Its absolute value, ie beyond zero
Will be less than 7
And then we can solve it
We subtract 3 from both parties
5x> -10
Divide both ends on 5, and become x> -2
Now here, we subtract 3 from both parties
5x <4
Divide both ends on 5, and get x <4/5
And then we can draw vinegar group
It should be bigger than -2, not larger than
Or equal, and less than 4/5
Maybe this sounds like a conduit, but it's also
A space separator, if we say all x values ​​that fall between
2 and 4/5
Or we can write all the x values ​​that are larger than
-2 and less than 4/5
These are the x values ​​that achieve this equation
In fact, I want you to understand this
By visualization
Now, maybe you are seeing a rule here
I do not want you to keep it, but I will give it
If you want it
If you have something like f (x), the absolute value of f (x)
Be less than, let 's assume a number, a
is not it?
This is the case
We have f (x) <a
This means that | f (x |, or f (x) must be
Be less than zero less than a
If this means that (f) x must be less than a positive or
Greater than -a
This translates into that, which translates to (f (x>
-a and f (x) <a
But he came from the same logic
This must be assessed by something that is beyond
Zero is less than a
Now, if we go the other way, that is if we have something
F (x)> a
That means he has to evaluate something
The distance from zero is greater than a
If this means it is either to be f (x
Greater than the positive of a, or that (f) x is less than -a
is not it?
If it is less than -a, it may be -a -
1, or -5 + -a
Then when we take absolute value
Will become a + 5
If its absolute value would be greater than a
I just want to - you can save this if you want, but I do
I really want you to think about this, okay
This must be evaluated to be less than zero below a, this must be
To be beyond zero for more than a
Let's solve another example, because I know it can be
A little confusing
I encourage you to watch this show for many times
If this will help you
Let's assume that we have 2x | - Let me put
Something else here
Let me put a harder example
Let's say it's 2x / 7 + 9
> 5/7
If so, he must evaluate something that is beyond him
Zero is greater than 5/7
If this thing, ie 2x / 7 + 9, can be directly
Bigger than 5/7
Or it can be less than -5/7, because if it is
Less than 5/7, will be its absolute value
Bigger than 5/7
Or that the 2x / 7 + 9 will be less than -5/7
We have encountered this situation here
Then we solve each of these equations
Look if we ask - let us multiply everything by 7
In order to get rid of these denominators
If we hit both sides by 7, we get 2x + 9
× 7 = 63,> 5
Let's do this here too
We will get 2x + 63 <-5
Let's subtract 63 from both ends of this equation, and
We get 2x - let's see
5 - 63 = 58, if 2x> 58
If we put 63 of the two ends of this equation
We will get 2x <-68
I realized I made a mistake here
Subtract 63 from both parties, 5 - 63 =
I do not want to make any unintended mistake
And then divide both parties on 2
In this case, we get, x> - you do not have to
To reflect the disparate, because we divide on
Positive number -58 / 2 = -29, or
- Here, if we divided both sides on 2 - or x <
68 2 2 = 34
Thus, on the setup line, set this solution
The equation will look like this
That is the setup line
I have -29
I have -34
If the solution is, it can either be greater than 29, and
Greater than or equal to, if greater than 29, that is
Located there, or can be less than -34
If any of these will achieve differentiated absolute value
this is
.